[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers einen
guten Samstagabend ihnen allen wo mir
silensky ist auf einer Mission im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und fernab
seiner Heimat er will Überzeugungsarbeit
leisten bei den engsten Verbündeten auf
dem g7-gipfel die ihm tatsächlich erste
Schritte Versprechen auf dem Weg zu
einer modernen ukrainischen Luftwaffe
silensky traf an symbolischem Ort in
Hiroshima aber auch die die den
russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
bisher nicht verurteilt haben und weiter
Geschäfte machen mit Moskau MRT Wissen
berichtet
wir wissen nicht genau ob das Wort F16
viel bei morgen Plausch von
Bundeskanzler und britischem premier
Richi sunak gilt als Triebfeder hinter
der Kampfjet Zusage bei der Scholz
diesmal nicht so entscheidend ist denn
der Wunsch des Mannes den sie hier in
Japan froh erwarteten wird von seinem
wichtigsten Verbündeten erfüllt wo lole
mir selenski bekommt von Joe Biden zwar
keine F16 Kampfflugzeuge aus den USA
aber grünes Licht an alle die selber
welche liefern wollen mindestens zwei
Dutzend vielleicht gar vier sollen es
werden nicht für die erwartete Offensive
sondern als langfrist-schutz gegen
Russland
jetzt ist der Moment um nach vorn zu
blicken und zu fragen was die Ukraine in
Zukunft militärisch braucht um
weitergehende russische Aggressionen
abzuschrecken dazu passen die F16
ich bin sehr glücklich vielen Dank an
unsere Partner es hilft uns unsere
Häuser und Familien zu schützen
genau das bekam dann auch der indische
premierzuhören der und seine Kollegen
aus dem globalen Süden sehen immer neue
Waffenlieferungen ja kritisch und
deshalb werben auch die G7 für selenski
Sache indem sie die Werte Frage stellen
respektieren wird das internationale
Recht respektieren wir die unkater und
dazu gehört Souveränität und
territoriale Integrität und wenn das ein
klares Ja ist dann gelingt es eben auch
Indien auf unsere Seite zu bekommen auch
nette Gesten können helfen aber viel
wichtiger sind wohl die 600 Milliarden
Dollar die Europa und Amerika den
Schwellen und Entwicklungs Ländern geben
für Infrastruktur und den Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel erste Projekte laufen
schon aber die Gäste der G7 fordern dass
all den schönen Worten weitere Taten
folgen Länder wie Indien und Brasilien
ständige Sitze im Weltsicherheitsrat
bekommen die Ordnung der Welt gerechter
wird daran entscheidet sich ob der
Westen ist auch wirklich ernst meint
es ist für uns in unserem Interesse
entscheidend dass der globale Süden zum
Partner wird denn es entscheidet darüber
welche gemeinsamen Werte verteidigen wir
und genau darum ging es auch bei seinem
abendlichen Plausch
viele hier hoffen dass morgen auch die
Gäste aus dem globalen Süden selenski
den Rücken stärken zumindest optisch mit
einem historischen abschlussbild für
diesen Gipfel
ist schon bemerkenswert diese Reise
Diplomatie von Präsident selensky Wissen
in Hiroshima wie groß ist denn die
Chance dass er da tatsächlich eine
Allianz hinbekommt die auch Länder
umfasst die bislang nicht auf Seiten der
Ukraine standen
also ich glaube die Chance ist so groß
wie nie zuvor seit diesem Kriegsbeginn
und das hat damit zu tun dass er hier
Gelegenheit hat unter vier Augen
gewissermaßen die Opferperspektive klar
zu machen das was in der Ukraine
passiert und zweitens auch allen klar zu
machen er nimmt Friedensangebote von
jeden wer vermitteln will sei es die
Arabische Liga sein ist die G7 seines
die Schwellen und Entwicklungsländer er
wäre sogar bereit weiterzureißen nach
China nach Peking in der Hoffnung dass
daraus ein Frieden entstehen könnte und
der präsentiert sich damit als einer der
ehrlicher Interesse daran hat als
Wladimir Putin der nicht bereit ist von
seinen Maximalforderungen abzurücken und
ich glaube das wird am Indischen premier
ganz ganz deutlich nicht nur dass er
zugehört hat wo du mir selenski sondern
kurz danach auch bei einem Treffen mit
den USA und Japan und Australien mit
ihnen darüber geredet hat wie kann man
verhindern dass die Lage im Indopazifik
eskaliert also wie kann er auf der einen
Seite fordern dass die
territoriale Integrität für Taiwan gebar
geworden bleibt aber dann im Grunde
zurückweisen dass die territoriale
Integrität der Ukraine gewahrt wird also
ich glaube da kommt hier der ein oder
andere ins Nachdenken und dann immer
vielleicht noch ganz kurz und ein
bisschen insgesamt gesehen ist die Welt
auf diesem Gipfel jetzt enger
zusammengerückt oder haben sich die
Gräben die es ja tatsächlich gibt noch
klarer gezeigt
ich glaube die Linien sind sehr klar auf
der einen Seite die G7 mit Angeboten
eben an die Schwellen und
Entwicklungsländer auf der anderen Seite
China das klar sagt hier ist wieder der
elitäre Club der den anderen die Regeln
aufdrücken will und das stimmte
sicherlich auch über 70 Jahre haben die
USA wirtschaftliche Macht genutzt um
anderen auch Regeln aufzudrücken aber
sie wir wollen allen hier sagen jetzt
ist es anders wir wollen das alle etwas
von neuen Regeln in der Welt haben und
sie bieten eben Teilhabe am Tisch und
ich glaube die USA und die G7 meines
Dienst diesmal Ernst gegenüber diesen
Ländern und versuchen damit klar zu
machen dass sie die bessere Variante
sind als China die Einschätzung von MRT
wissen immer vielen Dank in der Ukraine
selbst werden lange quälende Ängste
jetzt immer akuter die Schlacht um
bachmut die wohl längste und blutigste
des gesamten Krieges erklärt der
russische söldnerchef Jewgeni brigoshi
heute für beendet und gewonnen von
offizieller russischer Seite gibt es
dafür keine Bestätigung die Ukraine
dementiert und rund um das Atomkraftwerk
saporicia einer Gegend die Schauplatz
sein könnte für die angekündigte
ukrainische Großoffensive stellen sich
die Menschen so gut es geht auf eine
weitere Eskalation ein von dort Tim
Krüger
früher hat er direkt am Atomkraftwerk
saporicia gelebt Alex Schupp war dort
Ingenieur nach vier Monaten ist der wie
viele Mitarbeiter vor den russischen
Besatzern geflohen an diesem Tag hilft
er bei der Ausgabe von Hilfsgütern für
andere geflüchtete der Kontakt zu den
Kollegen die noch immer in der
Atomanlage arbeiten werde immer
schwieriger sagt er weil die Russen
jeden Kontakt verhindern wollen die Zahl
der Besatzer im Atomkraftwerks stetig
das ist für die Mitarbeiter ziemlich
verstörend sie sind sowieso moralisch in
einer schwierigen Lage
schon kurz nach Beginn des Krieges wurde
rund um das Kernkraftwerk gekämpft die
Angst vor einem Unfall ist seit der groß
auch wenn es von Russen besetzt ist wird
es noch immer von ukrainischen
Mitarbeitern betrieben
auch der Bürgermeister von Erna und da
jener Satellitenstadt am Atomkraftwerk
ist geflohen er spricht von schweren
Misshandlungen gegenüber den
Mitarbeitern
bringen Menschen mit ukrainischer
Meinung in Polter Kammer einige kommen
nicht lesen zurück einige sind danach
gesundheitlich geschädigt oder psychisch
gebrochen
und nun steht die ukrainische Gegend
Offensive wohl bevor und könnte auch das
Gebiet der Anlage betreffen
die meisten von uns besorgt ist die
Frage wie schwer die Besatzer das
Atomkraftwerk und die Stadt vermiet
haben es wird viel Arbeit werden die
Minen zu beseitigen
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
IAA hat die nuklear-anlage mehrfach seit
Kriegsbeginn besucht hat Beobachter vor
Ort und waren ebenfalls vor der
aktuellen Situation das Gelände sei von
den russischen Truppen zu einer
Militärbasis umfunktioniert worden sagt
die ukrainische Betreiberfirma
die Besetzung des Atomkraftwerks ist
derzeit die größte Bedrohung wenn
Radioaktivität freigesetzt wird dann
bedroht dass die ganze Welt
aber glaubt daran dass die ukraineischen
Truppen das Kernkraftwerk ohne
schwierige Gefechte befreien können dass
die Russen fliehen dann wieder so
schnell wie möglich zurück in seine
Anlage und sie wieder ins Netz zu
bringen
so und weitere Nachrichten jetzt in der
Übersicht von Diana ja da blicken wir
auf die verheerenden Überschwemmungen
und Erdrutsche in Italien in der Region
Emilia Romania wurde die Alarmstufe Rot
wegen weiterer Niederschläge erneut
verlängert laut Behörden mussten
mittlerweile mehr als 36.000 Menschen
ihre Häuser verlassen mindestens 14
Menschen starben die Zerstörung ist
allgegenwärtig und 100 Gemeinden in der
Region sein betroffen erklärte die
Vizepräsidentin der Emilia Romania
die Bundesregierung will mehr
Pflegekräfte aus dem Ausland anwerben
konkret aus Brasilien im Juni will
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil deshalb mit
Außenministerin bärburg in das
südamerikanische Landreisen das sagte er
der neuen Osnabrücker Zeitung geplant
sei eine anwerbestrategie mit Ländern in
denen es mehr junge und gut ausgebildete
Menschen gebe als der dortige
Arbeitsmarkt aufnehmen könne erklärte
Heil Absprachen gäbe ist auch mit
Indonesien und Mexiko
ab heute können in Deutschland lebende
Türkinnen und Türken ihre Stimme für die
Stichwahl um das türkische
Präsidentenamt abgeben wie hier in
Hamburg bildeten sich teils lange
Schlangen vor den Wahllokalen bis zum 24
mai sind rund 1,5 Millionen
Wahlberechtigte zum Urnengang aufgerufen
bei der ersten Runde stimmten in
Deutschland 65 Prozent für den
amtierenden Präsidenten Erdogan gegen
ihn tritt Oppositionsführer Chemie
neben anderen Griechenland wählen Sie
ebenfalls das ist eine Wahl unter dem
Eindruck eines furchtbaren Unglücks Ende
Februar kollidieren zwei Züge neben
menschlichem Versagen ist der Grund wohl
auch marode Infrastruktur Missmanagement
Sparpolitik 57 Menschen verlieren ihr
Leben auf Massendemonstrationen danach
zeigt sich die Wut im Land jetzt kurz
vor der Wahl ist sie bei vielen
griecheninnen und Griechen eher
resignationen gewichen der amtierende
Regierungschef hat dem Land allerdings
auch wirtschaftliche Erfolge gebracht ob
ihm das morgen reicht wenn Griechenland
wählen geht aus Athen Andreas Postel
sie ist 1997 geboren und nennt sich
nephilie Mac mit ihrem YouTube-Kanal
erreicht die influencerin regelmäßig
zehntausende junge Griechen ihre
Generation kennt das eigene Land bisher
nur im krisenmodus Finanzkrise
coronakrise Energiekrise
viele sind ins Ausland gegangen auch
wenn ich der Meinung bin dass die Dinge
nicht mehr so schlimm sind wie sie es
2009 waren
viel Aufmerksamkeit gab es von ihrer
Community für ein Interview mit dem
griechischen Ministerpräsidenten
Kyriakos im Wahlkampf ihm schlug Kritik
entgegen wegen eines Abhörskandals und
der Versäumnisse vor dem Zugunglück im
Frühjahr aber mit so Tages wird
angerechnet dass er in seiner
Regierungszeit ein Stück weit Vertrauen
in die Zukunft geschaffen hat die
griechische Wirtschaft ist doppelt so
stark gewachsen wie im europäischen
Durchschnitt internationale
IT-Unternehmen wie hier in Thessaloniki
bieten neue Jobs und die Löhne steigen
wenn auch langsam ist das Universum das
alles in Verbindung mit einer
Verbesserung der volkswirtschaftlichen
Eckdaten hat ein Klima eine positive
Wahrnehmung in der Gesellschaft
geschaffen trotz des immer noch
niedrigen Einkommensniveaus sind rund
45% der Griechen der Meinung dass die
Wirtschaft besser da steht als noch vor
vier Jahren
zudem habe Mittagessen im Land zu
internationalem Ansehen verholfen
deshalb wird der liberal konservative
zum Wahlkampf vor der Akropolis um eine
zweite Amtszeit
mit ganze Seele bin ich meiner
Verantwortung gerecht geworden und das
Land zu regieren und das werde ich
weiterhin tun die Alternativen sind
weiter vorangehen oder wieder umkehren
[Musik]
bislang kommt der Aufschwung längst
nicht bei allen an nach zehn Jahren hart
im sparkhaus infolge der
Staatsschuldenkrise ist das
Verarmungsrisiko in Griechenland hoch
trotz staatlicher Hilfen
54 Euro habe ich dazu bekommen einmal im
Monat 54 Euro da muss ich trotzdem hier
nach dem aller billigsten suchen um es
kaufen zu können
soziale Gerechtigkeit ist das große
Thema von Oppositionsführer Alexis
zypraß
Wahlkampfabschluss der Linken sirizer
auf dem syntakma Platz in Athen
Schluss mit der sozialen Ungerechtigkeit
Schluss mit Profitgier Schluss mit der
Ungleichheit
Umfragen zufolge ist eine absolute
Mehrheit für keinen der Kandidaten in
greifbarer Nähe schwierige
Koalitionsgespräche und sogar Neuwahlen
werden bereits erwartet am Sonntag haben
die Griechen die Wahl wer wie stark im
neuen Parlament vertreten sein wird
der erste Absteiger der
Fußball-Bundesliga steht seit heute fest
Hertha BSC spielt künftig in der zweiten
Liga die Enttäuschung ist groß denn im
Heimspiel gegen den VfL Bochum führten
die Berliner bis in die Nachspielzeit
dann aber kam der Ausgleich entstand
eins zu eins mehr dazu gleich nach uns
im Aktuellen Sportstudio und jetzt zu
den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die
lauten 5 6 24 33 34 42 Superzahl 3 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
und so wird das Wetter in den kommenden
Tagen morgen im Nordwesten bereits am
Vormittag gewittrige Schauer sonst viel
Sonne am Nachmittag dann auch im Osten
und Südwesten einzelne Schauer und
Gewitter 20 bis 29 Grad am Montag bei 20
bis 29 Grad im Osten sonnig sonst teils
kräftige Gewitter Dienstag noch
unbeständig Mittwoch wieder
meistfreundlich aber nur noch mit 16 bis
23 Grad und wir entlassen sie in diese
Nacht mit einem Satz über den es sich
lot nachzudenken er stammt von Marken
Amis einem der einflussreichsten
britischen Schriftsteller der eine
Ära prägte und dessen viel zu früher tot
heute bekannt wurde
when the past ist forgotten a present is
unforgettable
danke für heute und gerne bis morgen und
die nächsten Nachrichten gibt es hier
gegen 0.25 Uhr mit Christopher Wehrmann
tschüss
[Musik]